l'histoire étreint la france en cet
hiver 76 le rapt plus le meurtre d'un
jeune garçon épouvante à temps l'auteur
fut cynique odieux
les mots se sont alors emballée soir la
france a peur un enfant est mort un 12
enfants au regard profond assassiné
étranglé ou étouffé on ne sait pas
encore le top 6 ne l'a pas complètement
révélé par le monstre qui l'avait
enlevée pour de l'argent patrick henry
est une relation de la famille il fut
interviewé à plusieurs reprises avant
son arrestation il n'était alors que le
suspect numéro un les parents viennent
de lancer un appel au ravisseur est à
dire qu avait quand même beaucoup de
coïncidences reconnaissait bleu vous
même qui faisait quand même que vous
auriez pu enfin vous corresponde
exactement ouais bien sûr bien sûr il ya
eu des cas un silence qui ont qui ont
fait que lier pose c'est pourquoi la
police est adressé à moi c'est les
coïncidences
puis il ajoute au micro d'une radio
votre avis moi je pense que c'est oui le
corps du petit garçon fut découvert sous
le lit de la chambre d'hôtel que patrick
henry avait loué l'assassin est
indéfendable
il encourt la peine de mort que 400
manifestants viennent réclamer à
l'ouverture du procès dans une
plaidoirie flamboyante robert badinter
son avocat arash patrick henry à la
guillotine il est condamné à perpétuité
en janvier 77
robert badinter devenu garde des sceaux
combat lors la peine de mort
entre autres à partir de l'exemple de
patrick henry sachez bien que dans la
foule
tu as 3 rien au passage de bus fait de
bons temps au tour du palais de justice
amr pu faire à moins bon temps se
trouvait un jeune homme qui s'appelait
patrick henry croyez moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je les a pris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur qui choisit que la
peine de mort
après 24 ans de cellules patrick henry
attendent derrière les murs de la prison
de caen aux yeux du ministère de la
justice
il présente aujourd'hui toutes les
garanties possibles d'une réinsertion
prisonnier modèle il a consacré sa
détention aux études un travail l'attend
à sa sortie qui pourrait intervenir
avant l'été